le président a besoin de vos immédiat ne
pensiez que c'était un deal devrait pas
être là je suis avec les services
secrets attention à toi vous ne verriez
plus jamais ça qu'est ce que vous faites
sans peur peur à tous
mais le phénomène du ciel ne se fait pas
vous devez ne rejoindre tout c'est va se
reformer
il serait prudent de rentrer monsieur le
président tout de suite pour tout
détruire
pardon de vous faire maintenant nous
battre
si la tempête avait reçu des elle va
augmenter en châle fait leur force
non c'est terminé sell sera pas à tant
qu'on n'aura pas compris le phénomène
est pourquoi il se reproduit son sein ce
sont donc toutes les villes de la côte
est qui sont en alerte rouge
papa j'ai besoin de ton aide c'est une
idée que vous travaillez à la nation est
l'indépendance va bientôt décoller
numéro 15 déclarent la guerre
jusque dans l'espace
surveillance
pas le seul héros et la famille
je vais revenir tu me le promets
shark n'a de trois jurys